so historically the control of disease
has been an
important driving force for the
development of states as we think of
them today
so charles tilley famously argued that
wars
make states and yet historians have
shown that in as much as military
conflict
it was war against an often more deadly
foe than an enemy army
disease that prompted the extension of
the state
into previously autonomous social
domains
on the one hand contagion prompted the
development of institutions of control
civilian law enforcement agencies police
customs migration
intelligence services quarantines
and pandemics led to the establishment
and strengthening
of health bureaucracies city health
boards
that marked the exertion of
unprecedented state power
over societal actors like the church
city boards regularly
overruled the clergy in prohibiting
festivals processions and gatherings
on the other hand contagion also
encouraged the development of
institutions of care
such as poor laws relief for the needy
that underlay the emergence of welfare
states
the control of disease and healthcare in
general
thus gradually went from being a private
realm
dominated by religious and kinship-based
organizations
to being recognized as within the
jurisdiction of
and then also a key responsibility
of a state towards its people so
roosevelt famously said that the success
of failure of any government in the
final analysis
must be measured by the health of its
citizens
and key to this is the protection
against disease
but if we think of conceptualizing how
capable states are
in terms of how effectively they control
infectious disease
it's important to recognize that this is
a particular
type of state capacity that rests
critically on a state's ability to gain
compliance with society
so let's think for a second of the
typology of the kinds of activities that
states regularly
undertake on the left you have tasks
that states can achieve
without much active participation from
society economic planning the
dispensation of justice
building of public infrastructure on the
right
on the other hand are activities that
states cannot be successful at
without the compliance of society so the
best organized elections are only
successful if people vote
volunteer armies can only be raised if
people join them
a state's tax base often its main source
of revenue
rests on people willingly fairly paying
taxes
a state's public health policy is only
as successful
as the extent to which people comply
with it
historically states have elicited
compliance with their policies on this
rough spectrum
from coercive to voluntary on the
coercive
end forcible inspection raiding of homes
separations of patients from families
segregation of contacts compulsory
sterilization compulsory vaccination
laws that may or may not be accompanied
by force
but such coercion is far from ideal it's
costly to implement you need to have
information you need to monitor and
punish
those who are evading and further
coercion
risks societal pushback
through much of history people have gone
to great lengths to resist public health
mandates
in india colonial reports document how
families hid
plague victims in lofts in cupboards
in gardens in addition to such evasion
across much of the world coercive public
health policies have provoked
protests uprisings violent riots
even assaults on and the assassinations
of state
employees moving across the spectrum
away from coercion many states stop
short of making vaccines compulsory
but they may require them for access to
state resources
schooling employment and at the very end
of this scale
we can think of compliance with public
health interventions
that is voluntary willingly extended
this is the most desired type of
compliance
but it is also the most elusive it
represents a category
within state tasks that require popular
participation
that following a group of fellow new
england economists i call
wicked hard